in the middle of the night it exploded
into life a dramatic and terrifying
brush fire right on the doorstep of Los
Angeles it is the speed with which these
fires can spread that make them so
deadly on the nearby freeway the lights
of those who listen to the warnings and
got out these fires are being driven by
the sort of strong dry winds that come
this time every year to devastating
effect through the night and into the
morning firefighters trying to save
homes some of them beyond help this is
Tiger Tail Road and it is the area
that's been hardest hit by this fire you
can see what's happened to this house it
is all but destroyed and the house next
door they're still pumping water onto
that house because this thick choking
smoke still billowing up from behind the
house being driven by these winds these
are some of the most expensive homes in
America among those who ran for their
lives the actor and former California
Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger warning
his neighbors not to screw around with
evacuation orders and praising
firefighters as the true action heroes
who charge into danger the message to
those who stay behind has been blunt if
you're in the mandatory evacuation zone
and you're still there watching this
you're an idiot get the hell out it's
way too dangerous people that stay
behind are just endangering themselves
and not helping it is just one of
numerous fires across the state in wine
country thousands of acres have burned
power has been switched off to whole
communities to prevent downed power
lines starting more fires tens of
thousands of people were told to head to
shelters to think of it coming through
Healdsburg and Windsor and into Santa
Rosa that's that's a little like
overwhelming and scary
you know that it could be that big you
don't want it to be that big well we had
a mandatory evacuation early this
morning and we had over here for there
our experience
two years ago we were evacuated here
because we have the pet the fire crews
across the state the weather forecast
offers little hope of any relief soon
but while some will return to find
real-life Horrors in Halloween week so
far no lives have been lost in all this
devastation
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles